so it is a rainy day in August here in
my home studio you've got my chalkboard
behind me you can't see it here but the
dogs are laying in the corner cat next
to them interestingly enough all taking
it easy it's one of those kind of days
this is the second of my my channel
updates the new type of videos that I'm
going to start doing regularly where I
talk about what I did over the last
month what I got coming up for this this
present month of august 2013 and I'm
going to talk about YouTube stuff but
I'm also going to talk a little bit more
broadly about other things in my
professional and even even personal life
so the first thing to talk about is
actually you notice that the crutch is
going and that's a good thing doesn't
mean I'm entirely out of the woods yet
but I'm able to get around with a leg
brace my knee those of you didn't see
the previous video I tore some ligaments
in my knee at first it was thought to be
a sprain and then is actually they
misdiagnosed it in the emergency room
even though the guy interestingly don't
listed himself as being a specialist
they misdiagnosed it as a sprain I went
to my regular physician and he said well
you need an MRI they had an MRI went to
the specialist and he has it turns out
I've torn not just one but two ligaments
damaged the meniscus and scrambled up
some of the bone marrow inside of the
bones in my knee you know the leg bones
so it takes some time to heal I've got
to do several months of physical therapy
before they're going to actually do
surgery to put new ligaments into my my
knee and hopefully it'll be good as new
after that there will be a lot of
physical therapy afterwards the
specialist told me that it's going to be
about the year total recovery time from
which took place back in June so that's
that I'm getting around ok I had to do
quite a lot of traveling over the last
month and i used the the crutch for
quite a bit of that along with a leg
brace and you know i was able to get
around most places some days it was
pretty tiring because you end up using
some of your other muscles to compensate
for for the damaged things and in really
in this case the damage is that the
ligaments are gone so i don't know if
you know this but you've got four
ligaments in your knee I've lost two of
them and those ligaments keep your knee
from going weird directions so my knee
can do the stuff that it normally ought
to be able to do for the most part it's
a little bit stiff doing full extension
and it's a little bit stiff going all
the way back the problem is is that it
can do a lot of things that knees aren't
supposed to do which are really bad for
the knees and bad for all the other
tissues and that's why I have to wear
the brace if I'm going to do any
extended walking and if I'm not wearing
the brace have to be really careful not
to mess up the knee further by letting
it go in strange directions i'm going to
watch the ground it's kind of a strange
experience maybe i'll talk more about
that in some other video at that more
length any case enough about that let's
talk about what what's going on over the
last month so for things mainly the last
thing that i was involved with the most
recent one was at the very end of july
and i've put a video from that that
conference it was the kiss me conference
the International Society for McIntyre
inquiry which in this case was held in
Grand Rapids Michigan a very nice town I
really enjoyed my time there and it was
hosted by Grand Valley State University
and there's it was kind of nice to go
there actually because I got to see two
people one of whom I didn't know but
actually graduated from my alma mater
Southern Illinois University he was
just entering graduate school as I was
leaving graduate school and I also got
to see an old friend and colleague in
Medieval Studies who I forgotten was at
grand valley state until he showed up to
one of the keynote addresses and I'm
looking and there he is so he commented
on a handsome paper I did Oh six or
seven years ago at a cpu and Mark moyes
was the one who organized that he's a
professor at Grand Valley State
specialist and Plato among other things
did an amazing job organizing the
conference I always loved going to guess
me and if you have any sort of interest
in virtue ethics or even in management
theory or stuff like that I would
strongly suggest that if you if you see
it's me being hosted near you it's on
it's on this side of the pond in
odd-numbered years and it's on the other
side over usually in Europe or Britain
on even-numbered years I would suggest
that you go great papers great
interactions it was morning tonight and
sometimes deep into the night you know
having beers at the at the local pub
talking about all sorts of things and so
that was that was great and I had a
paper that I don't I haven't entirely
finished writing on Anselm and how he
fits into McIntyre's history of
philosophy and understanding of moral
theory basically arguing that McIntyre
should have should have said more about
Anselm and here's the sort of things
that he could have said about himself
and I've got a presentation about that
you can you can see it if you want to
I've uploaded it I need to get that
paper revised and finished and then sent
up for publication and I've already got
a journal in mind for that so that was
that I did a radio interview as well
with the radio show theology matters
with the palace on blog talk radio and
this one was actually also about about
an some and I talked about the pros
logian argument
which is more than just prosto Jian 224
you know what people call the
ontological argument and some by the way
doesn't call it that that's Conte and
people after him that call it that
Anselm actually talks about one huge
argument that spans the entire work and
so I talked a little bit about that and
about how it was taking up the arguments
of Mona loggia and uniting them into one
argument talked about the origin of it
and psalms of attitude towards it then I
fielded some calls and it was a really
good time I've got another one coming up
and I'll talk about that in the things
to come in August what else I did some
personal videos not as many as I'd like
to have done I know that viewers have
been asking me for for a long time to
talk about my own philosophical
development about my interests outside
of shooting videos and philosophy about
my my own you know history about my
religious convictions and so I've been
I've been trying to get to those I
haven't done a solid job and churning
out as many of them as I'd like to in
part because I've been you know fairly
busy this last month this is this coming
month I'll actually have a lot more time
on my hands and I since i'm not able to
stand in front of the blackboard for
extended periods of time reliably yet i
think i'm going to continue shooting a
lot more personal videos the other thing
that happened was we took a trip out to
the midwest for our annual three-day
lemco no family reunion memories kohler
it's colton that's the reason why it's
called lemco but it comprises a whole
bunch of families all connected to the
LEM breeze route going back to my main
Pepe my great-grandparents who actually
he was he was born here in the United
States she came from from Canada his
father fought in the American Civil War
and came to the States because of that
he
took somebody's place across the border
for some money back then you can hire
somebody to take your your your slot and
so the family's been in the States for a
long time is a very close connected
family it's really wonderful that we
have that because a lot of people don't
it's a family in which first cousins are
as close as brothers and sisters and
many other families and third cousins
are as close as first cousins and so
it's great we do it every year we rent
out a park the kids love it because they
get to see all their cousins and run
around and it's very safe and fun the
adults it's nice to reconnect with all
of our families it's something that we
we've been doing for Wow since I was a
kid close to 30 years no close to 40
years yeah yeah the 1970s was when we
first started doing it I don't remember
ever not spending a lot of time with my
family and interacting with them so
that's something that's a real high
point of our summer it took you know big
travel of course to get out to the
Midwest and then come back so that that
took some time let's talk about now
let's talk about where wife got coming
up for the next month so um I've got a
lot more time on my hands and because a
few other things have a few factors had
fallen into place probably shouldn't
call them factors to one of them as a
person and it has more to do with her
absence than her her presence my wife is
currently in Switzerland doing an
intensive one month actually three week
residency at European graduate school
which is one of the top notch programs
for for continental philosophy was
started by by some some big-name
continental philosophers including
cluding dario if I remember right they
get people like slob oh geez yeah
and I've been bad and people like that
to come in and give your classes there
and so she's in the first year program
they're working on her her her doctorate
in philosophy and I think it's also
called contemporary media studies to
very cutting edge program very intensive
way up in the mountains we're
interacting by Google Hangouts once a
day and then you know text messages and
stuff like that she's having a great
time so that means that I am here at the
homestead and my schedule is fairly open
so I can get a lot of work done a lot of
things that need to get get attended to
um what else I'm just finishing up this
online class that's ethics class that
I've been teaching over almost the
entire summer for Maris College I
created an entire online learning
environment for my students that uses
some of the videos that I've shot in
previous classes and held some of the
core concept videos and then I have a
there's a lot of grading in my class
because I have the students do many
short assignments so that it reinforces
the learning it helps them apply it over
and over again then we build to a final
moral biography paper and then they have
to take a final essay exam that i have
set up so you know i can talk more about
that sort of pedagogical stuff i suppose
and some other video and my views about
online education because i have quite a
few but in any case august six is the
official end of the class which means by
about august eighth ninth tenth I should
have most of the grading done which
leaves me free for a while other than
designing my classes in putting together
learning environments for my classes
coming up this semester I'm teaching an
ethics class and an intro class the
ethics class i'm doing a few tweaks to
it but i've got that you know more or
less down the intro class every time
that i teach intro to philosophy i do a
different theme so like last year's
theme was dialogue and dialectics this
year's theme is going to be love
friendship and desire so we're going to
start out the first major work that
we're going to read is
no symposium and we're going to go all
the way through obviously we can't cover
everything but there's a lot of material
and will hopefully get all the way up to
people like Freud and Sartre you know
very modern views on unloved and and
desire and friendship and sexuality and
the students will compare and contrast a
lot of different models of different
types of love or affection and desire
and talk about you know whether these
are revelatory for us or whether these
conceal things for us all sorts of
interesting things along those lines
what else I'm getting some talks and
workshops ready for the fall we're now
in the booking season so to speak you
probably know that I'm a public speaker
I do strictly academic talks for for
academics sometimes schools will bring
me in to talk about a particular figure
been doing that sort of thing since I
gave this a man select your back in 2008
walking on some of my talks are actually
videotaped and you can you can see that
in the playlist I also do some very
popular talks and I'm going to be doing
some talks at libraries and perhaps even
at some some other organizations
including churches this coming semester
if I remember right on book to do a talk
at marist college for the Medieval and
Renaissance program specifically on how
the eight capital vices of the Desert
Fathers became the seven deadly sins
that we know today which is very
interesting history there leading from
you know John Cassian all the way
through Gregory 22 you know Thomas
Aquinas and then people subsequent to
you um what else tidying up my web
presence if you don't know this I not
only have you can see this on my youtube
channel I not only have a youtube
channel which is where I put a lot of my
work i have several vlogs which i
haven't been doing much with this summer
but i'm going to start writing for again
and i'm also bringing out a new blog
which i'm not going to say
much about until it's actually out
because I've learned that you know until
you actually get something done it's
probably not a great idea to talk too
much about it I have a face book author
page I have a good reads profile as an
author I have a Twitter Linkedin
academia.edu a few other profiles and
I've been starting to get solicitations
from various online I guess you could
call the websites or web platforms that
want me to be involved as an expert or a
designer or content producer so I've
been I'm not going to talk too much
about specifics with that maybe next
time I will but what I'm doing is I'm
actually like looking at these and
seeing are these the kind of ones that I
want to be involved with the kind of
ones that I want to invest the time and
where I you know be designing something
like like video courses for them or
being a on tap expert for for people to
consult I'm also doing some consulting
work and some some tutoring work for
various individuals and institutions
what else I've got another theology
matters coming up on august eighth so if
you're if you're interested in that sort
of thing it's a talk radio format I call
in and they interview me I'll give sort
of a rundown of what it is that I'm
going to talk about with the host and
then we have open mic open open for them
and I take calls and talk to people and
the topic this time around is going to
be Thomas Aquinas on natural law and I'm
going to talk about not just what Thomas
Aquinas means by natural law and how
it's a bit different than what some of
the other people later on you know like
say Hobbes and Locke mean by natural law
and even the new natural law theorists
mean by natural
I'm also going to talk about how the
natural law is connected with some of
the other things that Thomas is really
interested in like eternal law the
divine laws all the new law human law
and even what he calls the foam ace of a
sin and we'll talk about how it can be
used as a moral theory and as a ground
for talking with religiously uncommitted
people it provides a useful ground for
religious people to talk with with
non-religious people I think and we'll
see where it goes I really enjoy that
that sort of format so it should be a
lot of fun what else have I got coming
up going to be shooting some videos I'm
going to shoot some more personal videos
where I talk about my own philosophical
development so people have asked me for
example well you had a saurian phased
you ever have a vid continued in phase
as it turns out I did I also had a low
justice phase i also have other thinkers
sort of like lonedell where I never got
out of the phase and I'll talk about
some of those people that have been very
important in my own philosophical
development like Aristotle or Alistair
McIntyre and I think I'll do a few other
videos about things that I'm
particularly interested in that are
important from my own life like like
cooking for example and culinary matters
and I've been I've had a lot of viewers
wanting me to talk about my own
religious convictions and my history
with that sort of thing I've been
putting those sort of videos left for
quite a while but I'll do at least one
of those this month so I've been kind of
reluctant to talk about that sort of
stuff for a variety of reasons but I
think it's time to bite the bullet and
actually let viewers know where where I
stand on that sort of stuff so I'm going
to do that and as soon as I'm able to
i'm going to start shooting course
videos again obviously towards the very
end
the month i'm going to start shooting
videos from my my intro to philosophy
course which i'm going to record this
entire semester but i'm also going to
start preparing some videos for my my
intro students that I think could be
useful for other people I'm thinking of
a sequence of videos basically centered
around the theme of how to read X where
X is some philosopher you know giving
getting some pointers for thinkers that
I've been reading for a long time how if
you're approaching them for the first
time you can get a lot out of them what
to look out for what to keep in mind as
you're reading them why you know why you
shouldn't get discouraged if you don't
get it the first time that sort of thing
and so I'm going to start out with
play-doh and sort of work my way through
some of those maybe in front of the
chalkboard some of those maybe maybe in
other places i'm going to start shooting
the existentialism videos again I've
been doing a lot of reading in lab chest
off who is somebody haven't talked about
yet so I think I'll probably start with
him I've got some other people that I
need to get to like Aubrey Oh Marcel
obviously we need more Heidegger and
Sartre and Camus and people like that
couldn't hurt to have some more
Nietzsche and Kierkegaard and I just
sort of scratched the surface with
Dostoevsky so there's a lot of
existentialism videos coming up
eventually I'm envisioning about a
hundred videos in that sequence right
now I've got 31 done so that gives you
an idea about how much more is coming
after I finish with that but that's
going to be several months from now I'm
looking to do a sequence on Hegel's
phenomenology of spirit going from the
very beginning all the way to absolute
knowledge but that's that's you know
further in the distance there's a few
other projects that I'd like to sort of
bring to a conclusion i started out
shooting what i wanted to be a sequence
of videos on Aristotle's texts and
that threw the first one of them the
very first four chapters of the
categories before i got my knee injury
and i wasn't able to be in front of the
chalkboard so now it's time to finish
out the category is very important wrist
italian work that that's kind of hard to
approach and then I think I if I've got
the time i'm going to start plowing
through some of Aristotle's other works
obviously I've done some you know course
videos before on Aristotle's Nicomachean
ethics but his corpus is much wider than
that and I'm thinking that that I could
do an entire sequence on Aristotle
sports Aristotle somebody was very
important to me who have been reading
for years I publish on and working on a
book on Aristotle and anger that that's
probably a good place actually to bring
this to a close one of the other things
that I'm doing over this next month is
putting my ducks in a row as far as the
scholarship that I'm supposed to be
working on I've been working for years
on to book projects one is on Aristotle
and anger and one is on handsome and
moral theory and actually some of the
videos and talks that I've given our
dovetailing with those I always think
that I'm going to you know do a talk and
it's actually going to like inform the
book writing but it ends up being
something a little bit different which
is good which is fine it's just that i
need to actually buckle down and start
working on this book the chapters for
this book not an article over here not
something over there working on this
book the chapters for this book and not
an article / over there that said I also
have to do some work on articles as well
I've got a few conference papers that
have given recently on the unsane
handsome that need to be tidied up or
parts of them need to be rewritten some
some other things need to be added to
them in footnotes and then they need to
be sent out to journals for publication
I've been a little bit lacks with that
over the last two years because I've
been doing a lot of online work you know
with the videos and
and the other web presence stop the
blogging but I think it's time to really
start getting the academic writing back
into high gear I used to churn out you
know I shouldn't say try Alex they were
high quality work you can see in my
academia.edu page but I used to you know
publish you know anywhere from two to
four articles academic articles per year
not including you know book chapters
book reviews and I need to get myself
back into the habits that that are
required in order to sustain that level
of productivity because I really enjoy
writing about these things so this this
coming a month it's going to be heavy on
handsome sum Aristotle stuff but mostly
on an some and getting those those
papers finished revised sent out to two
publishers that's probably going to be
going on for a couple months with the
end zone I've got some Aristotle papers
actually put a few of them that they
need the same sort of process I've got a
few Hobbes papers a few papers on
Alistair McIntyre some papers on
phenomenology some on Thomas Aquinas
there's a lot of stuff that I've got
that needs to actually get sent out and
find a home so that's something where I
may be putting a lot of my my effort so
that tells you what's going on with me
now that I've actually laid it out i'm
not sure how to get it all done like I'm
going to be awfully busy but at least
that gives you an idea if you're an
interested viewer about the sort of
things that you can expect again if you
like the sort of things that I'm doing
with YouTube you might like some of the
things I'm doing with my blogs or on
theology matters you know with fellows
that that show or you might check out my
academia.edu profile and look up some of
my writings if you're if you're
interested in that sort of thing or you
don't go to my facebook page where I
give updates about what I'm
doing day-to-day put interesting
articles get into conversations and
occasionally arguments with other other
Facebook users so that is what we've got
going on for the month of August and I
will leave it at that